Phoenix Arizona is a monument to man's
arrogance it's a city of 5 million that
should not exist an Endless Sea of
concrete asphalt and single-family homes
in the desert briefly interrupted by a
small group of skyscrapers temperatures
during summer normally reach about 40
degrees celsius with 330 days of
sunshine each year despite the dry
hellish desert climate the lones are
Lush and green nearly every house has a
swimming pool and the city is dotted
with large virgin golf courses all this
in the wake of a historic drought and
accelerating climate change Phoenix has
been called at the least sustainable
city in the world for good reason
climate change plus 5 million strong
Desert Cities do not go well together
and to put it mildly and what's this oh
at philosa we're on a mission to create
a more Equitable and sustainable future
by starting with a clean slate we have
this really unique opportunity to focus
on what's most important we're not just
building a new city this is a new model
for society we will create a 15-minute
City that promotes active and
sustainable modes of transportation Mick
excuse districts that ensure all daily
needs are within a five minute walk from
your house we're going to create
efficient buildings we're going to have
a diverse source of renewable energy
Supply to generate more energy than we
consume the same thing with water
generating enough water to supply the
future of telosa and potentially even
other communities through efficiency
Recycling and Technology we'll start
with 50 000 people a really diverse
group and from that seed grow into this
incredible city of 5 million people
[Music]
for you to experience to close that for
you to be a part of it
foreign
[Music]
City envisioned and spearheaded by Joe
Rogan's secret brother former Walmart
CEO and billionaire Mark lore so what is
wrong with this project what is wrong
with building a 5 million inhabitant
techno fever dream City in the middle of
the desert I like how they already have
shiny CGI of the whole thing but they
don't yet know where the city will be
even detailed planes and visualizations
usually come after you've secured the
location completed surveys geodetic
studies and so on anyway so teloza would
start with 50 000 inhabitants and then
gradually grow to 5 million and my first
question is why why would anyone want to
live there in the middle of nowhere even
in a cursed place like Phoenix had a
reason to exist originally the land was
arable and local farms could sell their
produce to a nearby mining town delosa
is not being built for any practical
reason it's not like they found a great
place somewhere in the U.S and said wow
this would be a good place for a
sustainable City no instead a
billionaire decided he wants a
sustainable City then started looking
for a place to put it in the desert the
good thing about building a giant City
in the river desert is that land is
cheap the bad thing about building a
giant City in a remote desert is that
you're building a giant City remote
desert in order to sustain a 5 million
City you need a lot of water and I mean
a lot where would you get it from even
if you find a location with a water
source slapping a 5 million City on top
of it would absolutely destroy it by
sucking everything dry and Water
Reclamation alone isn't enough to solve
this water is constantly evaporating and
you have to keep replacing it that
replacement usually occurs naturally via
rain but not in the desert obviously you
would need to find a place with ample
water but chances are land won't be
cheap there because it is likely being
used by others we already have enough
problems with nimbees when trying to
build a rail line let's say all the
lawsuits delays protests obstructionism
enough to turn planner's hair gray now
imagine trying to build a city of 5
million there Humanity would go extinct
before he would even get through the
first round of long suits in the empty
desert you don't have such issues but
you would need to pipe in water from
somewhere else which means costly and
complex pipes and pump infrastructure
spending potentially hundreds of
kilometers so yeah now let's talk about
how tiloza could be powered and oh my
god did they seriously put windmills in
the middle of the city these might look
nice and futuristic if you know nothing
about windmills but they produce noise
that would drive people mad over time
vibrations that would damage surrounding
buildings not to mention cities tend to
have erratic wind patterns for a variety
of reasons putting windmills in the
middle of your city is the equivalent of
putting your solar panels in the living
room by the window instead of your roof
otherwise they plan on supplying the
entire city with Renewables as
advertised by this page from their
website which might actually break the
world record for a number of buzzwords
per line distributed flexible and
Expendable carbon neutral Energy System
redundant neighborhood microgrids
reliable and resilient energy and I mean
that's great but you also need to store
surpluses so you can use them during
shortages in the real world energy
storage is most often done by pumped
Hydro storage the most efficient and
eco-friendly Way by far you basically
have two reservoirs at different
elevations where you use Surplus energy
to pump the water to the upper Reservoir
while during shortages you let the water
down through a turbine gaining back
electricity when needed needless to say
there is no mention of any such
solutions from telosa it's just multiple
storage Technologies which is the
equivalent of yeah bro we'll have like
stuff to store the energy in Lowell very
promising another aspect of this project
is sociological who will buy apartments
in the high-tech desert city of the
future well if every single one of their
promotional pictures are a clue it's the
urban upper middle class this is despite
all their claims of inclusivity and
equality people living in impoverished
areas usually can't even afford to move
within their own City much less to a
brand new shiny future city in the
desert so even if telusa was feasible at
all it would quickly become a sort of
eco-apartheid city-state for the
affluent leaving the rest of us to fend
for ourselves case in point about that
world-class education they promise where
every student has access to the best
teachers and resources how how will you
organize and finance this also if you
want to get the best teachers for a 5
million City you would need about 50 000
that means 50 000 good teachers
subtracted from the U.S education system
for the sake of your desert Hunger Games
capital and this applies to all other
essential Services it's like when the
Egyptian dictator decided to build a new
capital city in the desert for the
Egyptian upper classes he can build
Egypt's largest and most advanced
Hospital there with the best doctors but
those doctors are then subtracted from
the Egyptian Health Care system so a
rich Egyptian will be able to quickly
have their tunisanco treated while a
regular Egyptian will have to wait six
months for a vital surgery to be
performed in a rundown hospital by
overworked doctors with obsolete
equipment we also need to talk about
another aspect of talosa
transportation
so is Talusa going to have an efficient
environmentally friendly public transit
system well an architect firm is
designing Road air and hyperloop capable
autonomous spots for telosa I'm about to
have a stroke according to their fever I
mean Vision these will be pods to which
you can attach road wheels or rotors
thereby being able to function as a
self-driving car a hyperloopod and a
helicopter and as a cable car now I've
already made videos about my autonomous
cars and the hyperloop are terrible
ideas you can go check those out for an
in-depth look as for the helicopter idea
this is flying cars all over again think
of how loud the average drone is now
make the Drone 30 times bigger yeah not
to mention the risk of crashes also on
the renders there doesn't seem to be an
engine or a battery it's just a CG ski
lift cabin with four Chrome propellers
you might notice that all of teloza's
Transit Solutions are individual there
is no proper mass transit only small
parts carrying a handful of people and
that kind of Transit is fundamentally
unsustainable think of us traffic gems
in the pollution they cause the space
they take up inside cities and so on and
I'm glad they have 15-minute walkable
neighborhoods but that's about the only
Sound Idea of this project all in all
teloso is a great example as to why
billionaires shouldn't be allowed to
design our cities they are victims of a
phenomenon called Elite projection a
term coined by transit planner Jared
Walker Elite projection is the belief
among relatively fortunate and
influential people that what those
people find Convenient or attractive is
good for society as a whole billionaires
are used to living in remote high-class
effluent areas so naturally it would be
good for everyone they have access to
the best possible Healthcare and
education so everyone else in their
Utopia should damn the consequences for
the rest of society they've never set
foot on public transportation so
naturally individual pods are the way to
go and so on in its current form teloso
has a ton of problems so how do we fix
them easy if Mark lore wants to create
sustainable places to live in the US he
should start somewhere else places where
lots of people want to live and where
there is plenty of space to build namely
the downtowns of most American cities
picture theory is the center of Detroit
where most spaces occupied not by
buildings but by Urban freeways and
surface parking lots why not Lobby for
zoning Law changes and help densify the
area with sustainable housing or if you
find downtown then prices too high I
have good news for you just outside the
center there is a plethora of cheap
rundown half abandoned single-family
home areas just waiting to be bought and
redeveloped just imagine what you could
do there with some eco-friendly mid-rise
housing and Detroit doesn't have a
drought problem either why insist on a
desert city in the middle of nowhere why
not just fix existing U.S cities instead
actually I know exactly why you see
around the time I made my video about
neon they saw the airline City
project one of its hired Consultants
reached out to me we had a conversation
where he explained the true extent of
the EDSA behind the scenes obviously I
cannot share his name picture or even
recorded voice for fear of prison or
execution but I will summarize what he
told me basically these projects begin
with a billionaire dictator having a
stupid megalomaniac idea they then hire
Consultants from a consultancy firm to
visualize said idea basically to create
a metric ton of CGI then comes the
private presentation Edition where you
have five minutes to sell your proposal
to them as these people have very short
attention spans on the other hand they
are very easily Bamboozled by shiny CGI
and Wild Tech ideas so if you cram your
5 minutes full of those they will listen
and likely approve your proposals don't
even try to get into the details of the
project as in feasibility infrastructure
planning sociological service and so on
because they will fall asleep they don't
care they just want to see something
shiny and bombastic to bambooz of them
and boost their ego this is how you get
neom in the Saudi desert Dubai in the
emirati desert the new administrative
capital in the Egyptian desert and now
telosa in the American desert they are
all different yet they're all the same
Mark lore tries to ape Middle Eastern
dictators to bring about the Utopia he
thinks is best for you however he will
likely not succeed because as we all
know by now smooth brain dictator plus
construction project equals dumb so
this was the low side the desert Hunger
Games capital or I guess in this case
thirst games and I thank you for
watching if you wish to support me
making content like this please consider
subscribing to my page patreon and I'll
be seeing you next time